you had said earlier that screenwriting
in a sense is its own version of life
and death where it's about life and
death in some sense sure screenwriting
isn't necessarily about physical life
and death always although it can be
depending on your story but it is about
the life and death of the character
anytime you set out to write a script
it's about the evolution and
transformation of that character if you
do your job effectively
your character starts at point a and
you're trying to get them to point b so
for your plot through the character's
journey
they have to evolve and transform into
someone totally different
to take your audience on that same
emotional journey that you're trying to
lend through your character so i believe
that life and death doesn't have to
always be physical in a screenplay it
sometimes can be that emotional life and
death too